[موسيقى]
وفق ضيفنا اليوم هو موعد انطلاق مونديال
قطر 2022
اولي فريق المشارك في البطوله الى قطر
ويصير بالفعل بعد ساعات الفريق الياباني
عشاق الكره المستديره وتعيدهم بتجربه لا
تنسى وتؤكد انها جاهزه ومستعده لكن هل
العالم ومستعد لعلها الفرصه الاكبر منذ
احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر 2001 غير
الغرب المنطقه من منظور مختلف بعيدا عن
الصوره النمطيه السلبيه التي لحقت
بالانسان العربي والمسلم والتي كرسها
الاعلام الغربي
هكذا وصفه امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن
حمد الثاني من كل يوم الاول واعتبرته
جماهير المنطقه العربيه البالغه 450 مليون
نسمه ملكا لها دافعت عنهم في شراسه ضد
الحملات غير المسبوقه التي طالته اليوم
الاول وتتفاعل حذتها كل ما اقترب الموعد
وعلى المستوى الرسمي ايضا وفي ختام القمه
العربيه منذ ايام اكد اعلان الجزائر على
الدعم قطر في استضافه المونديال ورفض حمله
التشويه والتشكيك المقرضه التي تفعلها اما
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم الفيفا والذي
اعلن ان من اهم اهدافه اخذوا رياضه كره
القدم الى اماكن جديده واراضي جديده فقد
اكد راسه ان البطوله ستكون الافضل في
التاريخ منذ انطلاقيها لكن منظر اسيره
شبهات حول ملف قطر وتساؤلات عن فوزي ورغم
تاكيد التحقيقات نزاهه لم تتوقف الهجمه
وطرحها مؤدجوها رائعه عن حقوق الانسان
وحقوق العمال حتى عن المعايير البيئيه وعن
استعداد قطر ثقافيا وفكريا استضافه
البطوله القطريون رد باتمام كافه
الاستعدادات لاستضافه الفرق الرياضيه
والمشجعين من كافه انحاء العالم وباصلاحات
تشريعيه سباقه في المنطقه فهل تلعب هذه
الاطراف التي وصفها وزير الخارجيه القطري
بالقله في الوقت بدل الضائع في قصتنا ما
وراء الهدمه على استضافه قطر للمونديال
نرصد انطلاقه الحملات على قطر من الصحافه
البريطانيه حيث نشرت مقالات وقصص اخباريه
يغلب عليها التحرير ضد قطر غير ان المحرك
عنوانه المصالح الماليه والتوجهات اليمنيه
المعاديه للمسلمين فريقنا تعقب ترى رائحه
النفط التي تفوق من حمله الدنمارك ضد قطر
وازدواجياتها في ملف حقوق الانسان كما
رصدنا الموقف في فرنسا حيث قررت بلديات
اتباعها سياسه الشاشات السوداء كما سمتها
بينما مؤسساتها شركه في مشاريع عديده
منافقه
سبقيه القصه مع ضيفنا السيد ناصر الخاطر
الرئيس التنفيذي لبطوله كاس العالم 2022
عن كيفيه تعامل اداره البطوله مع هذه
الهجمه ورؤيته لاسبابها وعن متى تاثيرها
في استعدادات اللحظه الاخيره وبيلا انطلاق
البطوله لكن لمشاهد القصه ومن بعدها نبدا
الحوار
قطر في ورطه البحث 2022
[موسيقى]
فيفا فولكاب اي اس كاكا
ليله الثاني من ديسمبر 2010 وقبل ان يفضل
حضور للبعض دعوات فيفا للتطور نحو بلدان
جديده عندما خلص التصويت لمنح قطر حق
استضافه كاس العالم 2022 فبريطانيا التي
سحبت ترشيحها لتنظيم نهائيات 2022 في هدف
كسب ملف تنظيمه نهائيات 2018
الورشه تعرضت لخساره خاطفه امام روسيا
لتشن فيها حملات صحفيه صببت جاما غضبها
على الفيفا مشككه في ملفات عروض الدول
المتنافسه
وكانت قطر العنوان الرئيسي لهذه الحملات
والعزبه كمال
[موسيقى]
عندما عندما
لكن اعتقد ان بعض القصص التي سربت للاعلام
البريطاني ليس لها اساس من الصحه 2010
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نظمت بطولات كاس العالم في اوروبا وامريكا
اللاتينيه
لقد بدات في امريكا الجنوبيه ثم اوروبا
في تنظيم بطوله كاس العالم
البريطانيه
كان 66% منها سلبيا وتسعه وعشرون
على راس القائمه
[موسيقى]
الصحيفه المحسوبه على الشعبويه البريطانيه
اليمنيه كانت 80 بالمئه من تغطيها
لاستضافه قطر لكاس العالم سلبيا الصحيفه
ومؤسسات اعلاميه كبرى اخرى من بينها شركه
كاس العالم في الشتاء لما سيكلفها من
خسائر هائله حيث تمتلك المجموعات حقوق بث
بمليرات دولارات لمواسم رياضيه تعقد عاده
السابق في جامعه لندن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاسباب الرئيسيه اما اقتصاديه او سياسيه
انها كي تقام في قطر فيجب ان تؤجل من
الصيف الى الشتاء ما اثر على عوائد عدد
كبير من الشركات ومحطه التلفزه الغربيه
وبرزت كذلك مساله قناه بي ان سبورت سلمى
مملوكه لقطر والتي استحوذت مسبقا على حقوق
بث الفعاليه في عدد كبير من الدول
الاسيويه وبلدان الشرق الاوسط ايام
المساله في جزء منها كانت متعلقه بالعوائد
وثاره اشاعه وتسريبات حول تقديم عرض
بملايين الدولارات
من قطر الى مكان اخر
ومن جانب اخر استحوذت استضافه كاس العالم
2022 على 43
% من تغطيه ذال تلكراف لاخبار قطر اضرب
وجت لسحب الاستضافه من قطر محاوله ربطها
بمواصفاته بالاسلام المتطرف
الصحيفه المحسوبه على يمين الوسط المحافظ
كانت من اوائل الصحف التي رسخت ربط
الاسلامي بمفاهيم التطرف منذ 900 وفق
دراسه بعنوان دور الصحفي البريطانيه في
تشكيل المواقف المعاديه للاسلام والمسلمين
هذا مثال اخر على الاعلام المنحرف خاصه
الى جناح اليمين الذي يمارس تاثيرا كبيرا
على طريقه اداره الامور السياسيا اجنده
تتمثل بايجاد خندق بين دول يعتبرونها
ممتازه ويجب ان تضم المنظمات والبطولات
الرياضيه الكبرى وبين بقيه العالم الذي لا
يحق له استضافته هذه البطولات
الحملات التشهير بملف قطر في الصحف
البريطانيه بلغت ذروتها في محطتين الاولى
الحشد الاعلامي لسحب ملف المونديال من قطر
بدعوه فساد الفيفا عام 2011 و 2014 وانتهت
باعلان نزاهه الملف القطري عقب نشر نتائج
تحقيقات اجرتها لجنه الاخلاق بالفيفا
استمرت عامين
ثقافه كره القدم لكن هذا ينطبق على
الولايات المتحده عندما نظمت كاس العالم
عام 94 وكذلك اليابان في 2020
صحيفه الجارد لما اعتبرته كشفا عن عدد
وفيات العاملين في انشاء قطر
منذ البديل بانشاء البنيه التحتيه لكاس
العالم
وعندما تحدثنا مع منظمه العمل الدوليه
ومنظمى كاس العالم وجدنا الارقام اقل
بكثير وعلى مدار 10 سنوات فسيكون هناك عدد
من الوفيات واذا نظرنا في اسبابي هذه
الوفيات نعم كانت هناك وفيات في مواقع
الانشاءات وخلال العمل لكن ايضا كانت هناك
وفيات جراح حوادث الطرق حسنا في المملكه
المتحده لدينا حوادث طرق ولا ناتي قوانين
العمل خاطئه اذا كانت لدينا اسئله مهمه لم
نتلقى اجابات واضحه
لكم
تنظيم كاس العالم في روسيا حينها لم تكن
روسيا قد غزت اوكرانيا ولكنها كانت قد ضمت
شبه جزيره القرم وكانت حقوق الانسان قد
انتهت في روسيا في ذلك الوقت ظهرت
انتقادات لكن لم اكن مخطئه لم يكن هناك
حديث عن المقابره
اكسبريشن
قطر
مع دول الكبرى لاسيه مصينو وروسيا وفقا
لدراسه اعدتها هيئه مراقبه اخلاق ولوائح
الفيفا وعلى الرغم من الاصلاحات النوعيه
التي اجرتها قطر وكان على راسها الاصلاحات
نظام الكفاله ورفع الحد الادنى للاجور
وحمايتها ومنح العمال المهاجرين حق تقديم
الممثلين عنهم كسابقه هي الاولى من نوعها
في الخليج الا ان تغطيه هذه الاصلاحات في
الاعلام الغربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السامسونج
الاخبار سيئه مفضله على الاخبار الجيده
وقد لمسنا هذا في تقرير منظمه العفو
الدوليه الذي نشر مؤخرا فقد خلص التقرير
الى ان تغييرات كبيره اجريت واعترف بها
لكن الاعلام فضل التركيز على الجوانب
السلبيه المتمثله بالتقصير في تطبيق هذه
التغييرات وهذا ينطبق بلا شك على معظم
التقارير
[موسيقى]
الغربيهم وهم احرار في في مكان السكن لم
يعد هناك وضع يكون فيه العامل مملوكا لفرد
اخر وبينما لا يزال معظم العمال يعيشون في
مساكن فقد تم تطويرها ويتم اعاده بنائها
بشكل تدريجي ولم تعد المساكن ذات الحاله
السيئه قيد الاستخدام
[موسيقى]
للاجور وضمن مستوى المعقول من وجهه نظره
حيث يتضمن الاجر اقامه وواجبات مجانيه
وعند مقارنه ذلك بالمملكه المتحده وجدت ان
متوسطه اجر العامل يبلغ بعد الضرائب الفن
الى الفن و100 باوند بناء على الحد الادنى
للاجور هنا وبعد ان يدفع العامل اجره
المسكن والطعام الى ذلك والتي تبلغ حوالي
800 لا يتبقى له سواه حواليه 200 باوند
اكتساب القدر المكافئ للعمال في قطر نجد
ان القيمتين متساويتان تقريبا
[موسيقى]
لقد قارن بين اعداد العاملين في مواقع كاس
العالم وبين العاملين في مواقع الانشاءات
الاسلاميه والتجاريه في المملكه المتحده
وقد وجدنا ارقام متماثله من الحوادث
لقد زرنا عددا من مساكن العمال الوافدين
للنظر في ظروف الاقامه وشروط الرعايه
الصحيه وما اثار اعجابي فعلا هو الرعايه
الصحيه المقدمه للعاملين والتي يمكن
مقارنتها بما تتلقاه في المملكه المتحده
[موسيقى]
في الشارع
فهنا في فرنسا
سياسه الشاشات السوداء لمقاطعه عرض
مباريات المونديال في الاماكن العامه
بدعاء وحمايه البيئه وحقوق العمال وعلى
الرغم من تعاهد قطر بتعويضات الكربون الا
ان الحملات تتجاهل برنامج التعويض الذي
تتبناه البلد
كاس العالم اخذت هذه الاصوات تعلو اكثر
فاكثر والسياسه في فرنسا تتخذوا منحى
متطرفه
مع ذلك شخصيا ارى ان الدعوات في فرنسا
لمقاطعه كاس العالم تاتي في الغالب من
اشخاص لا يهتمون كثيرا او لا يهتمون بكره
القدم ومع ذلك يبدو انه كره القدم غالبا
ليسوا في وارد دعوات المقاطعها
يمكن ان يتحركوا بطريقه مختلفه بدلا من
الاحتجاج يقبل البطوله لكننا نرى نوعا من
سلوك القطيع هنا البعض يحتاجون واخرون
يدفعونهم كالقطات هناك من يحتاجون بنيه
حسنه لكن اخرين لهم ما اهرب اخرى
على الصعيد الرسمي ساهمت شركات فرنسيه
كبرى في تنفيذ رؤيه قطر الوطني 2030 من
حيث البنيه التحتيه والاقامه الرياضيه
ووفقا الخارجيه الفرنسيه فالمنشات
الفرنسيه الراسخه في قطر وعلى وجه الخصوص
في التحضير لبطوله كاس العالم 2022
راقصات الموت في ان من بين من يدعون
للمقاطعه اولئك الذين لا يحبون ان يروا
بلدا مسلما ينظم بطوله كاس العالم
على تنظيم المونديال
لقد ظهرت منذ اختيار قطر لتنظيم كاس
العالم لكنها حين ذلك متعلقه
علينا ان نستثمر كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
مواقف بعض الدول الاوروبيه المنوئه
للاستضافه العربيه منذ اعلانها لم تكن سرا
لكن مواقف بعينها انقلبت في نقطه تحول
على هذه الرقعه الخضراء في اسباير
الاكاديميه الرياضيه القطريه وقبل سته
اعوام تحديدا في مارس 2016 قدم الامير
فريدريك اندريس وليعهد الدنمارك وعقيلته
الاميره ماري الدعم الكامل لقطر في
مشروعيه الرياضي لصحبه وفد رفيع المستوى
من مسؤولين الدنماركيه وطرح نجم كره القدم
في نشر الوعي بثقافه الطاقه النظيفه
في هذه الصوره التي استوقفت زار الامير
فريدريك ووافده شركه مارسكونج كبرى
الشركات الدنماركيه والتي عملت على تشغيل
اكبر حقل النفطيا في قطر منذ العام
1992 بموجب اتفاقيه اعلنت قطر عدم تجديدها
في النصف الثاني من عام 2016 معتبر ضربه
قاسمه للشركه التي تساهم باربعه عشر
بالمئه في الناتج الاجمالي المحلي
عرضتها لبيع اصولها شركه نفطي
[موسيقى]
بطوله كاس العالم في قطر
انت معظم السياسيين كانت اجاباتهم لا
نستطيع الاجابه عن هذا السؤال كالا لا
نقاطع ولكن يجب ان نوجه الانتقادات اي
انها اجابات في معظمها متردده فلا احد
يريد ان يقاطع فعلا
شركه الملابس الرياضيه عام الانترنت
والاتحاد الدنماركي لكره القدم راس حربه
في حملات لم تجد غضاضه في اعتماد شركه
هامل في 93% من انتاجها على عماله في دول
تم الابلاغ فيها عن مخاوف بشان حقوق
الانسان وقوانين العمل
القسريه على الاقل لديها للعمل في شركات
البسه كبرى ووفقا لتقرير رويترز مواجهه من
جهات رات فيه حيله تسويقيه لزياده مبيعتها
كون الفريق الدنماركي هو الوحيد الذي
تعاقد معه عمل كمصنع للاطقم الخاصه بهم
لكاس العالم 2022 في حين حصلت شركات
الالبسه الرياضيه الاخرى على عقود مع فراق
عارفين
ان تتدخل الشركات في مسالتي حقوق الانسان
بايمانك فعلا بحقوق الانسان
ومحاولته ايجاد فرق على الصعيد السياسي
وما مد ارتباطه بالمال وبرغبتك في بيع
منتجاتك
والقميص داكن جدا
في المملكه المتحده والتي كانت تهدف الى
تخفي ديون العالم الثالث يرتدون اس بيضاء
وتبين انها مصنوعه في الصين وجزء منها
ربما من خلال عماله مضطهده لذا انهم نجد
هنا ازدواجا في المعايير
[موسيقى]
لما الاتحاد الدنماركي لكره القدم ستلاحقه
اتهامات بالعنصريه ليس بدءا بانتقال حقوق
المنتخب الدنماركي لكره القدم للسيدات
برفض الاتحاد مساواه اجورهن المتدنيه
باجور اللاعبين الذكور علاوه على المعامله
سيئه لهن والاستعداد الرديء لبطولات
السيدات والانتهاء بالشعارات العنصريه
التي ترفع في مدرجات الملاعب الدنماركيه
حتى تجاه الاوروبي غير الدنماركي
[تصفيق]
طب خلاص تقريبا
حقوق الانسان
لكنهم يريدون مناقشه موضوع قطر الوطني
[موسيقى]
في ايسلندا قابلنا اجمد ريان عضو المفوضيه
الاوروبيه لمناهضه العنصريه والتعصب الذي
عكف طوال عامين على تتبع ممارسات العنصريه
في الدنمارك ليصدر تقرير المفوضيه في
يونيو 2022 من 44 صفحه
[موسيقى]
الكلمات المستخدمه في القانون الدنماركي
وفي الحديث السياسي في الدوله
ناس غير غربي
وقد تم استبدال المصطلح تدريجيا بمصطلح
اخر وهو المجتمع الموازين
الكثير من الناس من انحاء العالم كافه
اشتروا بطاقات المباريات بسرعه مثل كعك
العيد
اتسائل ما اذا كانت ما تزال هناك بطاقات
ام انها بعد جميعها
كاس العالم كاس العالم هو اكثر فعاليه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جدا بتلك الملاعب فهم من بنوها وهؤلاء
العمال المغتربون هم الذين ساعدوا في بناء
اقتصاد قطر وشيد البنيه التحتيه التي هي
اساس الاقتصاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نرحب بكم مجددا المشاهدين الكرام وبضيفي
الكريم السيد ناصر الخاطر الرئيس تنفيذي
لبطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم في قطر لعام
2022 استاذ ناصر اهلا وسهلا فيك شكرا
لقبول الدعوه نعرف ان جزاكم مزدحم كثيرا
لكن هناك بعض النقاط التي تبقى تنتظر
توضيح للجمهور العربي الذي ينتظر بفارغ
الصبر هذه البطوله التي يعتبرها ايضا
سبقوا ان صرحت وقلت ان هذا اليوم فعليا هو
اليوم الحقيقي لانطلاق البطوله وانه سيكون
شعور مميز بالنسبه اليك شخصيا اشعار
اي صراحه يعني الناس كلها تنتظر 20 نوفمبر
لبيت بطوله كاس العالم لكن احنا فعليا
بالنسبه لنا وفراق العمل بدل عمل بشكل جاد
قبل فتره واحنا فعلا حسينا ان احنا دخلنا
اجواء البطوله
ودخلنا في عمليات البطوله بشكل كبير
من يلعب في الوقت بدل الضائع قطر مستعد
واعلن ذلك يقولون بانكم على اتم الاستعداد
لكن هل العالم مستعد ان يستضيف بلد عربي
مسلم هذه البطوله بهذا الحجم في منطقتنا
العربيه
بشكل كبير
الصحف
المحطات الاعلاميه وسائل الاعلاميه اللي
هي كانت ضد قطر من اليوم الاول قطر تعرضت
لحمله من اول ما فازت بيترشح او باستضافه
كاس العالم
طبعا بدل الموضوع بحجم قطر
الامور تغيرت مع الوقت واحنا رجعنا الحين
شفنا انا نفس الامور اللي هم كانوا
يتكلمون عنها في الاول اللي هو المناخ
قلنا عدم ارس كروي في كره القدم مثل باقي
الدول ال ال الدول الاوروبيه تحس ان هذا
انه بطوله كاس العالم هي حكر لدول اوروبا
احتضنت 11 بطوله من اصل 22 بطوله طبعا ما
ترضى ان دوله مثل قطر او دوله عربيه مسلمه
تستضيف بطوله مثل كاس العالم على سؤالك في
كان تقريبا 40 مليون طلب على تذاكر كاس
العالم تنبيع ثلاثه مليون منها اللي هي
ثلاثه مليون
عدد الجمهور اللي راح يجي قطر احنا كنا
نقول دائما بين المليون ومليون و200 واحنا
الحين على الوتر اللي قاعدين نمشي فيها
على حجوزات الطيران وحجوزات الفنادق ان
شاء الله راح نوصل لهذا الرقم فكل
المؤشرات اللي يشوفها بالارقام عارف ان
شاء الله راح تكون استضافه ناجحه لكاس
العالم
الموضوع لان ايضا الهجمه صارت مكثفه
وتعالت الحده مؤخرا قال بان النفاق عدم
الموضوعيه ازدواجيه المعايير هي السبب
وراء ذلك تبعنا في فيلم الليله رصد لمواقف
بعض الدول نتحدث عن جهاد ايضا اما في همم
في بريطانيا كانت جهات اعلاميه وراء
الموضوع الثاني الاتحاد كره القدم همم
يعني عده جهات كانت وراء هذه همم
الانتقادات
وراينا ايضا في المقابل بانها ليست ايديها
ليست بريئه تماما يعني هناك ازدواجيه
حقيقيه في المعايير انتم كيف تعاملتم مع
هذه الانتقادات منذ البدايه
الموضوع الانتقادات في انتقادات لازم
يتمرد عليها ان كان رد اعلامي ان كان رد
قانوني همم طبعا ليس كل شيء يكون على على
المراه الجميله في بعض الانتقادات
يعني الانتقادات على المراه الجميع يعني
وسائل الاعلام العالميه لم تدخر جهدا في
ذلك وكانت حملها شرسه وهنا كمان
انه لم يكن مستوى رد الفعل من قبل قطر على
مستوى الهجمه التي حدثت
لنا الاولويه هي نجاح هذه البطوله
والتركيز على تنظيم هذه البطوله باكمل
الوجه همم في بعض الانتقادات اللي صارت
طبعا احنا على 12 سنه انتقادات تعودنا
عليها في انتقادتها كثير ردي لنا عليها
بشكل صريح على في الوسائل الاعلاميه وفي
بعض عضلات يستحق الرد عليها جرائد صفراء
يعني يمكن نقدر نقول كل الجرائد اللي احنا
كنا همم نتوقع منها المصداقيه نتوقع منها
الشفافيه
المسؤوليه المهنيه في في في المجال ااا
صارت كلها جرائد صفراء للاسف
فمات يعني ان احنا نرد عليها كلها لكن
اللي تستحق قررت كنا نرد عليها ان كانت
بطرق عربيه او كانت على على
الاعلام
من العمال الذين توفوا جراء هذا في
الانشاءات تم تكذيبه صحيح همم في قطر وحتى
منظمه العمل زمان السيده شرارا تحدثت بان
هذا الرقم خطا وحتى يعني بعض الوسائل
الاعلام اعتذرت عن عن ذلك لكن لم نسمع
رقما من عندكم ما هو الرقم الحقيقي يعني
لم يكن هناك رد رسمي يوضح الاموره ويقطعها
في اطارها الصحيح
الفيلم اللي تم عرضها اشكركم عليه اولا
لان انا لخص كل الانتقادات اللي رضت لها
قطر من فوزا باستضافه كاس العالم الى
اليوم وفاندتهم وايضا اشرحها كثير من ال-
من ال- من الامور اللي كانت همم يمكن مش
معروفه للناس يعني رقم 6500 اذكروها
منظمات ان هذا رقم خاطئ انهم المنظمات او
وجهات الاعلاميه اللي روجت لها هذا الرقم
وهي الجاردينو الجاردي تاسفت ان هي عارضت
هذا الرقم بشكل خاطئ هم هم يعني اخذوا
اجمالي ارقام الوفيات على مدى سنتين او
ثلاث سنين وضربوها بعشر سنين
6,500 ماتوا همم في بناء استعدادات كاس
العالم
في انشاء مستندات كاس العالم ثلاثه ثلاثه
على اعلى المستويات
طبعا
في نقطه مهمه قالت ان بعض الامور الاعلامي
حب يذكر الامور السيئه والسلبيه احنا
ذكرنا هذا الرقم اكثر من مره لكن الجهات
الاعلاميه لا تحبنا تذكر الارقام هذه
الحديث
بالامور الجميله والطقس الجميل يعني نحن
للاسف نركض وراء الاخبار السيئه وهي التي
تتصدر العناوين من هنا اعود لسؤال مره
اخرى كيف بنيتم استراتيجياتكم لاعلاميه في
الرد على كل هذه الافتراءات والابداعات
الادعاءات من وجهه نظركم طبعا
احنا بعض الردود كان لازم نرد بعض
الافتراءات والتهامات كان كنا لازم نرد
عليها ان كانت بطريقه اعلاميه او ان كانت
بطرق قانونيه في بعضها يعني انا اهتمام
وشفنا مع الوقت ان هذه الاتهامات من
الجهات والانتقادات ومن الجهات همم يعني
لها اهداف سياسيه اهداف نقدر نقول ان فيها
عنصريه بشكل كبير ان دوله مثل قطر دوله
عربيه اسلاميه دوله صغيره قدرت ان هي
تقارع وتنافس دول كبيره يشوفون انهم احق
باستضافه هذه البطوله يعني ان قلنا خلص
استراتيجتنا نركز على عملنا نركز على انه
تكون نسخه كاس العالم في الوطن العربي
الاولى تكون من انجح نصف كاس العالم
هذه نقطه مهمه يعني
مونديال العرب منذ اليوم الاول مسؤولون في
قطر اكدوا على ذلك 450 مليون عربي هم
سعداء جدا دافعوا بشاراسه حتى على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لما تعرضت وتتعرضت قطر
لهذه الحمله بهاشتاقات يعني تصدلت همم
اكيد من الدول العربيه انا عربي ادعم قطر
هناك وعي في العالم العربي بهذا الموضوع
حتى على المستوى الرسمي كما ذكرنا هناك
على الاقل ظاهره همم دعم لملف قطر
هذه الحمله الشرسه هل همم تدركون حجم
المسؤوليه التي تقع على عاتقكم فعلا ما
الذي يمثله اولا لكم ان يكون هذا
المونديال فعلا ممثلا تكون قطر سفيره
للعرب همم وتقديم صوره ربما جديده للعالم
طبعا همم من البدايه همم قلنا ان هذه
البطوله تمثل كل العرب وهذه البطوله لكل
العرب همم ازيدنا حماس تزيدنا بالاحساس
بالمسؤوليه طبعا
وتزيدنا همم
رغبه في نجاح هذه البطوله عن كل العرب
المنطقه في غير يعني العناوين التي تتصدر
عاده للاسف في النزوح والتشرد والقتل
والحروب والماسي سار العالم فعلا همم
المنطقه العربيه بمنظور جديد كيف
استعدادتهم لذلك
من الغرب دائما كان انه
يصور المنطقه ان هي منطقه حروب ومنطقه
نزاعات طبعا بالنسبه لهم هذه البطوله اكبر
بطوله رياضيه في العالم انذار 3.2 مليار
نسمه راح تترجع الى قطر خلال بطوله كاس
العالم هذه راح تنسف طبعا ال ال الصوره
اللي كانت ترسم عن هذه المنطقه همم ان شاء
الله مليون نسمه راح يكون موجود في خطر
خلال بطوله كاس العالم هذا راح يكون سفير
للمنطقه سفير لقطر عندما يرجع ويقول اللي
شافه في قطر همم
تعرفها على الناس من المنطقه اللي راح
يكونوا متواجدين همم اثناء كاس العالم
فطبعا هذا مثل ما قلنا يعني الشعب العربي
واعي شعب العربي يمر بهذه اللي احنا
قاعدين نمر فيه دائما همم العنصريه همم
طبعا الصوره النبطيه اللي يحولون يرسمونها
عن المنطقه وان شاء الله ان شاء الله يعني
بطوله كاس العالم راح يتغير من هذه الصوره
في الانتقادات الاخرى همم هناك مناطق اخرى
من العالم ذكرت انه وحدها شرع مره البطوله
اقيمت في اوروبا فقط همم يعني هذا يدل على
الكثير هناك من لا يتحمل ربما ان يعني
منطقه غير اوروبا وغير هذه الدول الغربيه
المتقدمه الكبير انت تستضيف هذه البطوله
اود ان اقف معك همم قليلا مع منطقه من
العالم في الواقع لها في كره القدم
استضافت كاس العالم ولم تسلم هي ايضا من
الانتقادات البرازيل لا يعرف البرازيل حتى
ان كنت لست من متخصصين في الفوتبول لكن
نعلم بان الفريق البرازيلي له باع في هذه
المسابقه البرازيل التي خصنا في الواقع
وزير الرياضه السابق فيها خلال فتره قبول
ملف البرازيلي لاستضافه كاس العالم وهو
نائب حالي في البرلمان البرازيلي سيد
اورلاندو سيلفا خصنا بمقابله ولديه وجهه
نظر ايضا حول نظره الغرب لاستضافه الدول
تحت خط الاستواء لهذه المناسبات الرياضيه
الكبرى معانا نتابع استاذ النصر
او لا ارى ان قطر تتعرض لظلم ونظره
استوائيه غير عادله وتعاني من من يتعمدون
تجاهلها كثيرون لا يعرفون هذا البلد جيدا
ولم يتعرفوا على تاريخه وثقافته ولكن
لديهم نظره عراقيه وهي اوضح نموذج لهذه
الصوره التي يريدون تقديمها عن اختلاف
الثقافات يريدون ان يظهروا ان الثقافه
الاوروبيه والغربيه
وكل ما ليس وفقا يتم التعامل معه
في التعامل مع القضيه
كاس العالم وعندما استضافت جنوب افريقيا
كاس العالم الدولي
طبعا كانت هذه وجهه نظر الوزير الاسبق
البرازيلي وهي وجهه نظرت تشاطر وهو العديد
من الدول في الواقع التي ربما لم تحظى
بهذا الشهر تحتقدون بان استضافه قطر ستفتح
مجال لدول اخرى مثلما تقول في استكشاف
اراد جديده
يتكلمون عن الجو الجو في الخط الاستوائي
في الصيف جاوب حار طبعا
استضافه البطوله في فصل الشتاء فتحت افاق
الناس قالوا انه مستحيل انك تستضيف بطوله
في في فصل الشتاء احنا البطولتين في فصل
الشتاء بعض الدوريات راح تتاخر شويه او
همم يعني شل تاثير الكبير اللي راح يكون
عليها اتوقع انه راح نشوف دول اصغر من
الدول اللي اللي عاده تستضيف البطولات
راحت تستضيف راح نشوف ايضا ممكن بطوله
تقام في الشتاء اللي هي العاده تقام في
الصيف يعني
قلت باننا همم
المسابقه في الشتاء حتى هذه النقطه التي
انتقادات كبيره ويكون الموضوع البيئه كل
ما صار حولها من تبريد هذه الملاعب
المفتوحه على العالم سواق لها الغرب على
انها كارثه بيئيه همم يعني بما تردون على
هذا الموضوع ما الذي قدمتموه في موضوع
البيئه التي هو موضوع مهم جدا بالنسبه
للغرب والمواطن الغربي
المشاهدين انه في اوروبا في كثير من
السادات وكل المنشات الرياضيه يتم تدفئتها
في فصل ال في فصل الشتاء طبعا لان احنا
نعرف ان التدفئه
تستهلك طاقه اكثر من التبريد هذه اول نقطه
الثانيه ان احنا كنا دائما نتكلم على ارث
اللي راح تترك بطوله كاس العالم ومن اهم
ال- ال- هنسميها
المكونات هذا الارث هو الارث البيئي احنا
احنا همم
السادات همم تم على همم اسس صديق للبيئه
راح تترك همم
بطوله خاليه من الكربون او صديقه للبيئه
انبعاث الكربون بانكم يعني وعدتم لكنكم لم
تفو بشكل كامل في هذا الموضوع
همم دشنت اول همم
او 900 جنريشن
اللي هو الطاقه الشمسيه توليد الكهرباء
بالطاقه الشمسيه
هذا مع الاثنين اللي راح تيجي راح تكون
راح تعود بالفائده على هذه البطوله لانها
راح تكون همم يعني راح قطر راح تستخدم
الطاقه الشمسيه ليه استفاء همم طلب الطاقه
وايضا تعاهدت قطر في خلال الخمس سنين
الجاي او ل30 راح تكون 20% من حاجز قطر
للطاقه من الطاقه الشمسيه في هذا الطبعه
كلها يعود على كاس العالم
الانتقادات صحيح انا قطر سباقه في المنطقه
في ما يخص نظام العمل الكفاله لعلكم باقي
الدول في المنطقه هذه الخطوات الكبيره في
هذا الموضوع حقوق العمال لحد الادنى
للاجور والكثير الانسان انشاء صندوق
لتعويضات ايضا والكثير من التفاصيل الا ان
الغرب حتى في هذه النقطه لديه انتقادات
وهي انتقادات وجهها يعني يتم التشكيك في
انكم تقومون بهذه الاصلاحات حتى تمشوا
حالكم يعني ايه وبعد كاس العالم ستعودون
عن هي الاصلاحات وتتراجعون عنها بما اا
يعني تردون على هذه الاتهامات
يعني ما راح تنتهي الانتقادات واتوقع ان
ايضا في وقت البطوله راح يحاولون ان
يدورون شيء على اساس انه ينتقدون قطر
على قطر من خلال كاس العالم احنا بدنا
نرجع نشوف رؤيه خطر 2030 اللي تم اصدارها
في 2008 تكلمت على حقوق العمال او وراء
فهيتهم واحنا دائما قلنا ان هذه البطوله
اي واحد ممكن يستضيف بطوله كرويه او
رياضيه وتكون هي بطوله عابره وتنتهي احنا
قلنا لازم نوظف هذه البطوله ونستخدمه هذه
البطوله للتقدم همم
من اهم المكونات اللي احنا شوفناها في
رؤيه 2030 لان كيف احنا نتقدم في ملف
العمال والعماله في قطر طبعا هل ننكر ان
كاس العالم سرعت في وتيره هذه الاصلاحات
والتقدم لا بالعكس كاس العالم كان من اهم
الاسباب اللي صار في تغيير الجذري في
العشر سنين اللي فاتت وانا تحدي اي دوله
ان كانت اوروبيه او في امريكا الشماليه او
امريكا الجنوبيه قدرت تقوم باصلاحات في
فتره قصيره مثلها قطر قدرت تشريعات تغيرات
بناء مساكن للعمال بمستوى رفيع جدا كلها
كانت يعني تفضل الرؤيا رؤيه 2030
طبعا كنا عارفين ان في كاس العالم هذه
لازم الامور نحطها يعني 500 على الفاسده
على وتر سريعه
جدا لكن وسائل الاعلام مره اخرى الغربيه
منذ يومين او ثلاث ايام فقط كنا نتابعه
على وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه تم التسلل الى
مساكن عمان وهم يعيشون في ظروف صعبه
وقاسيه نتساء لقد انا هل لديكم فرق تفتيش
هل تذهبون
لمعاينه الواقع غير الذي تقول التقرير
ربما التي تصيبكم وتكون مخلوطه
ومن 2016 لليوم قاموا بتغريبا فوق العشر
الاف حمله تفتيش على مساركن العمال
يعني هذه مرحله وهذه راح تاخذ وقت في
تشريعات في مثل ما قلنا المسار كان يتم
بناها في معايير جديده ووضعناها لكن هذه
تاخذ وقت لان يكون في تطبيق لها ايضا نحن
ما نقدر نتوقع عن كل شيء يتغير في يوم
وليله عشر سنين مش فتره كبيره لتغيير نظام
بشكل كبير لكن مع الوقت احنا نقدر نقول ان
في المنطقه العربيه الحين القدر
لكن طبعا على اساس انه يكون في تطبيق على
ارض الواقع بشكل كامل راح يكون في وقت
طبعا انا صحفي اقدر اطلع الخطا واقدر اطلع
الصح ما شفنا الصحفي راح يشوفونا التغيير
صحيح
والله لا هذا الكلام غير صحيح بالعكس هذا
الكلام اللي يقول ان فيه ناس طرده لتوفير
مساكن للمشجعين هذا الكلام غير صحيح في
بعض الحالات حصلت كون بعض ملاك العقارات
استغلوا انتهاء عقود
لايجاد فرصه بالنسبه لهم انه ممكن يستفيد
من كاس العالم بيرفع الايجارات لكن ان ان
بشكل
هذا الكلام صحيح
وليس مدونه لماذا ما التخوف ما الذي
تتوقعونه ما الذي تقوله لوائح الفيفا ان
حدثت همم امور قد لا ترغبون فيها على
الملاعب او حتى تصريحيه همم
شعارات سياسيه شعارات
ليس لها علاقه بقره القدم ممنوعه طبعا
يكون في رقابه شديده على هذا على هذا
الموضوع
بطوله كاس العالم هي بطوله كرويه تحدث كل
اربع سنين نعم هي بطوله توحد الشعوب دائما
على كره القدم خاصه في البلد المضيف في
البطوله هذه طبعا دائما يحاولون يستخدمون
الجهات اللي عندها او المؤسسات اللي عندها
اجنده معينه يستخدمون بطوله مثل هذه لكن
شفنا ان بطولات قطر صراحه استغلوها الناس
بشكل كبير لاجندات معينه ان كانت اجندات
اللي هي حقوق المثليين والى اخره هذه
بطوله رياضيه هذه بطوله كره القدم الجمهور
اللي جايه حابب يحضر مباراه كره القدم مش
جاي يشوف همم منصه بنتكلم على الامور
السياسيه لان الناس يشوفونها في بيوتهم
على الاخبار الناس يبون ينسون لذا تكلموا
وقال رئيس الفيفا خلونا نركز على كره
القدم هذه البطوله لكره القدم والاستمتاع
للجماهير تستمتع في هذه البطوله ايضا
القوانين البلد ثقافه البلد هناك من
استغلها بشكل سلبي في تخويف الجماهير
القديمه ما الذي تقصدون ما الذي تنتظرون
من مشجعين
2010 الى 2018 شفت ان اغلب الجمهور يحترم
البلد اللي هو فيه يحترم القوانين وما
نشوف مشاكل بشكل كبير
فاحنا متوقعين ان ان الجمهور راح يجي هنا
طبعا في تعدد ثقافات وفي تعدد طرق
الاحتفال للجمهور واحنا ايضا لازم نكون
نظيفين ونحترم ايضا تقاليد ولكن المهم
انهم يحترمون القوانين انه ما يكونون يعني
انه ما يهددون امن وسلامه الاخرين وانفسهم
اكيد اليوم بنظره الى الوراء بعد كل هذه
الوجع الراس والصداع
قطر يعني
المتابعين وصفوا ذلك يعني احنا استطلعنا
حولنا استطلاع الاراء الغالبيتهم جاءت
جمله تتكرر كثيرا حسنا من عندي انفسهم
يعني
الانتقادات اللي قطر الان الى الوراء هل
كان الموضوع يستحق عنها ما الذي ستجنيه
قطر الذي همم يعني تتوقع
هذا المونديال لقطر والمنطقه ايضا
يعني بالنسبه لنا كنا عارفين انا راح يكون
في انتقادات كبير على دوله عربيه دوله
صغيره مسلمه تستضيف هذه البطوله شفنا
شراسه الحمله استمرت مدار على على طوال
الفتره طبعا ممكن تتخذ ان احنا اخذنا
المركز الثاني واحنا قرانا الولايات
المتحده لكن هم فاز ولكن احنا يعني
منافساتنا يعني وصلتني للمركز الثاني وكان
ممكن نقول انه هذا بحدات انجاز لكن قطر
تحب التحدي وتحدث من قبل
وقطر استغلت هذه البطوله مش لنجاح بطوله
وبس استغلت هذه البطوله العمل الجاد
استغلت هذه البطوله للتطوير في البلد همم
اللي يشوف قطر قبل عشر سنين ما راح يعرف
كيف كيف اصبحت بالعكس وظفنا هذه البطوله
من صالح
المواطن والمقيم على على قطر وايضا بتكون
بطوله استثنائيه وتكون بطوله ايضا تشرف في
العرب
في عجاله وفي جمله اخرى لان وقت المخرج
يجد لي بان الوقت انتهى ما الذي تقولونه
للمشجعين القادمين الى قطر في كلمه اخيره
نقدم لكم بطوله مذهله وبطوله استثنائيه
وان شاء الله راح تكون بطوله انتم
تستمتعون فيها وترجعون بذكريات ايجابيه
ترجعون ذكريات
تخليكم ترجعون على قطر
شكرا
كده مو حلقتنا دمتم في رعايه الله والسلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]